هذه الاسئله متى يمكن ان تصل هذه الاسلحه
الى اوكرانيا وكيف ارضى
نحيل هذه الاسئله كلها الى ضيفنا من
واشنطن العقيد هارلم اورمان كبير الباحثين
في المجلس الاطلسي والمستشار السابق لوزير
الدفاع الامريكي سيد هارلمان اذا ضيفنا من
موسكو يقول ااه انه يجب انتظار وصول هذه
الاسلحه سواء الدبابات او الاسلحه او
الصواريخ بعيده المدى التي وعدت دول الغرب
بارسالها الى اوكرانيا قبل تقييم ما يمكن
او كيف يمكن ان يكون تاثيرها على المعارك
على الارض ما رايك بهذا الكلام
انا اوافقه الراي تماما ما كنت اقوله
دائما هو ان الغرب والولايات المتحده
كانوا بطيئين جدا في ارسال اسلحه تحدث
فرقا ارسال الدبابات بدون التجهيزه
الداعمه يجعل هذه الدبابات اهدافا للقوات
الروسيه حين نرسل الذخائر والمدفعيه هذا
ليس كافيا لكي يكون لاوكرانيا قدره فعليه
لاستعاده الاراضي التي فقدتها منذ الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير
والاسوا بعد هو انها لن تكون قادره على
السعاده
او تخلص من الاحتلال الروسي اعتقد اننا
حتى الان لقد ارسلنا ما يكفي
لنغير المعادله ولكي تعيد اوكرانيا روسيا
من حيث اتت قبل 24 من فبراير لكن حتى الان
الامور معكوسه سيد اولمان يعني القوات
الروسيه هي التي تتقدم حتى اللحظه في جبهه
الشرق والسؤال لماذا كانت الاستجابه
الغربيه بطيئه
لاوكرانيا بتزويدها بهذا السلاح وما الذي
تغير الان حتى
اصبحت الصواريخ بعيده المدى مسموح توريدها
الى اوكرانيا ولم يكن ذلك مسموحا في
السابق
اولا تقريبا الجميع في موسكو وفي الغرب
حسب ان الجيش الروسي فعلا كفوء
والتقدم وان تقدم الى كيف سوف يسمح لروسيا
بان تحتل العاصمه خلال ايام وربما على
الاكثر اسابيع ولكن تبين ان القوات
الروسيه غير كفوءه وحيندا بدا الغرب يعزز
دعمه لاوكرانيا من خلال ارسال مساعدات
وتجهيزات العسكريه رئيس الامريكي بايدن
منذ البدايه كان خائفا من تصعيد وقال
صراحه انه لا يريد ان يكون سبب في انطلاق
الحرب العالميه الثالثه كان الغرب بطيئا
ولكنه كان كريما اذا كان بطيئا في توفير
ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا بالنسبه الى الصواريخ
البعيده المدى سنرى ماسه يرسل او ما ارسل
لكن لا اعتقد ان صواريخ
سوف يكون لديه القدره على
للعروسه سوف يكون علينا ان نرى ما هي
الاسلحه التي ارسلتها اللي هي هاي مارس او
انها ابعد مدى ولكن لي تحقيقين شرح اكبر
في اوكرانيا دعونا لا ننسى ان روسيا بدات
تحضر حملات تصدي وكذلك الشتاء ياتي
همم برد الشديد واعتقد ان اوكرانيا ستحتاج
الى المزيد من الاسلحه والتجهيزات اذا
ارادت فعلا ان تصدر صوت وتعيدها الى مقابر
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير والا سوف نرى
في الجبهه المركزيه كما حصل في الحرب
العالميه الاولى طريقا مسدودا او سيبقى
الحال على ما هو عليه فيما يتعلق
بالصواريخ بعيده المدى كان المسؤولون
الامريكيون يقولون انهم لن يزود اوكرانيا
بها في السابق لانهم لا يريدون ارسال
اشارات سلبيه لروسيا بما يحول المواجهه
الى مواجهه روسيه امريكيه ما الذي حصل
الان حتى همم توافق الاداره الامريكيه على
ارسال هذه الصواريخ
التي ارسلوها هذا لم يرسل او لم يعلن عفوا
فالرئيس بعيدا قال سوف لن نرسل الطائرات
المقاتله اف 16 وبالتالي انا استغرب انه
ارسل صواريخ بعيده المدى او ابعد المدى
ولكن همم هنا نسال هل انا صواريخ التي يصل
مداها الى 300 كيلو متر سوف ترسل
استبدالالا لطائرات المقاتله يجب ان نعرف
ما هي الصواريخ حاليا انا لا اعتقد ان
الصواريخ البعيده المدى ارسلت او ستور
ولكن ربما انا مخطئ شكرا لكم
كبير والباحثين في المجلس الاطلسي
والمستشار السابق لوزير الدفاع الامريكي